hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar Pro quantum immunoassays
enable low level cytokine detection i'm
xavier chairs of lab routes and i'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by thermo Fisher Scientific
thermo Fisher is a world leader in
serving science whose mission is to
enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer for more
information on our sponsor please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers screen
labeled ask ask a question and click on
the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window and if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen
this is an educational webinar and this
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker
Magnus Mullen PhD a senior scientist at
Thermo Fisher Scientific dr. Mullen
graduated from UCLA University in Sweden
with a master's degree in biology and a
PhD in medical biology he father
followed this with a postdoctoral
fellowship at the University of
California San Francisco dr. Mullen is
now a senior scientist at Thermo Fisher
Scientific focusing on product
innovation as a part of the immuno
Diagnostics division for more
information on their speaker please
click on the speaker biography tab at
the top right of your screen dr. Muller
will now begin his presentation
hello my name is Magnus Walden and I am
a senior scientists working on
developing new tests for respiratory
disease such as asthma because we needed
new ways to measure low levels of
inflammatory proteins we use the new
program term high sensitivity immunity
in our research using clinical samples
and this is the work that I would
representing today
you
so I would like to give a personal
introduction to respiratory diseases
with a focus on asthma and then describe
the a/c workflow for the program to
immediacy that we used I will present
some data using clinic examples where in
one case we looked at a cohort
representing wheezing children in
another case we looked at asthmatic
children and both of these cohorts
concluded HTH healthcare control groups
finally I want to mention some results
we obtained from analysis of nasal and
fecal samples
you
background to respiratory diseases such
as asthma and COPD so these are figures
from the European language book based on
statistics collected with the Europe
within the European Union it has been
estimated that asthma respiratory
diseases altogether cost six million
hospital admissions and 600,000 death
every year in the European Union and
total cost for this is three and 300
billion where 200 come from asthma and
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
COPD which is a closely related disease
it has also been estimated that one
third of the population would develop a
slot sometime the problem with our space
that there is a heterogeneous and
complex disease with multiple clinical
phenotypes so currently there is no
really good biomarker for asthma
diagnosis prognosis or very very prompt
response as you can see in the
right-hand side of the picture in the
showing the bronchial and healthy
Airways asthma is characterized by
airway inflammation and swelling and you
oftentimes get an increase in nuclear
production and typically a narrowing of
the Airways which altogether makes
breathe breathing much more difficult
so there are several approaches to
phenotyping of asthma patients and there
is evidence for a genetic predisposition
to asthma so there may be reason to do
genetic or gene expression analysis it
is also well established that asthma
involves activation of the immune system
and the disease is characterized by the
presence of immune cells in the Airways
histologic analysis of airway biopsies
may be used to look at the extent of
inflammation and airway remodeling more
recently studies have shown that the
results role for the airway microbiome
in asthma development from a clinical
perspective attention is typically
focused on lung function assessing for
example bronchi bronchial hyper
responsiveness and of course important
information is also collected can be
collected by questionnaires to asthma
patients focus of this talk will be on
the inflammation part highlighted in red
this schematic cross-section of the
Airways shows the media mechanism
elastomer progression and severity as
not may be triggered by exposure to
allergens or pollutants or be caused by
viral or bacterial infections depending
on the trigger different pathways will
be activated involving different cell
types and cytokines the boxes that you
see in the picture indicate research
areas that will benefit from further
investigation and as you can see there
is a lot to study on your right hand
side of the slide you see some
approaches to identifying and measuring
molecules involved in airway
inflammation mass spectrometry is the
approach that allows for analysis of the
greatest number of analytes at the same
time and is typically used as the first
screening method candidates from a mass
spec analysis can then be verified using
for example a bead based assay such as
the record reflects immunizes
for single target validation traditional
methods like lights are typically used
but for sensitivity purposes we have
chosen to use the new program term high
sensitivity community
you
program
ss were recently introduced a little
more than a year ago and the menu
selection has rapidly increased while
there are many more kids for human
cytokines chemokines or growth factor
targets the menu from our mouse is
starting to expand although I only work
with human clinical samples I can really
appreciate the need for those with mouse
models working with small volumes that
do need a greater sensitivity targets
included in the studies that I will talk
about are indicated in bold in the table
compared to other immunity platforms
that I have my colleagues have used I
find that the main advantage with pro
Kadima analysis is the high sensitivity
which enables us to analyze much many
more samples using a minimal amount of
sample and altogether the protocol is
much simpler and fairly quick
current study we wanted to address one
problem that clinical research is face
the volume limitation of working with by
bank by bank clinical material for
research purposes clinical samples are
typically only available in small
volumes and this is especially true for
samples from children with the
conventional immune asset such as lysis
sample consumption is relatively high
and this is sometimes limits the number
of biomarkers that can be targeted so
the scope of this study was to try to
try and select the panel on candidate
targets supported by the literature is
relevant for respiratory diseases on our
clinical samples and one intention was
to see if Pro quantum Indian acids would
allow us to measure multiple protein
markers using only small volumes so that
we can make more use of precious samples
importantly we wanted to see also if
sensitivity was sufficient to Maester
measure basal levels of low abundance
biomarkers and regarding the focus serum
samples in the context of respiratory
disease was at the center but we also
looked at nasal samples representing
respiratory allergy and as I will talk
about at the end of the presentation in
a separate project we looked at fecal
samples representing irritable and
inflammatory bowel disease to conditions
that are typically assessed by a fecal
samples and we used program to assess to
see if those could also handle these
more difficult and complex sample
matrices
blood plasma and serum or very complex
mixtures more than 10,000 different
protists ranging in concentration by
roughly more than 10 orders of magnitude
it has been estimated that less than 10%
the volume of proteins have been
measured in a quantitative manner and
those are typically the most abundant
ones so the challenge is really in
detecting those low and ultra low
abundance proteins that are at sub micro
molar concentration levels and just to
give you an example on the left-hand
side I've indicated the typical
sensitivity of two diagnostics assays
use that we run on our um you know cap
in your cap platform we use them for
detection of proteins involved in
Allergy and Asthma as you can see the
detection limit for ESP and trip this is
around one nano gram per milliliter and
just to compare we have I put the
reference as a reference the measuring
range of one Pro quantum si the il-6 si
and it's measuring range what is
interesting to us is how well they
program the platform complements our
current systems by I lost allowing us to
go down in concentration and measure low
abundance proteins this enables us to
look for biomarkers in this case
cytokines that are relevant for
respiratory diseases
you
you
so some words about the experiment
details of the results that I will
present so we use Pro quantum analysis
that are listed on your right hand side
and we selected them based on their
relevance for airway inflammation and
some like il-6 and il-8 or consider
markers of neutrophilic inflammation
while others like i'll i'll thirteen any
attacks in Essos with associate with
elsa novella key information the two
main types of inflammation behind asthma
interferon gamma on the other hand is
typically triggered by viral infections
it could be a very nice complement to
the other markers as for the
instrumentation we use the quantity
acute is your instrument for the readout
and a cloud-based pro canto software
available a term official site at no
cost and i will go into further detail
on why this software the app may be very
handy and useful serum samples were in
all experiment diluted tenfold
you
about the clinical samples the serum
samples we analyzed the total of 168
human serum samples and these were from
two independent cohort where one cord
represented wheezing children 0 to 6
years old and the other cohort
represented older children that all has
the doctor's diagnosis of asthma
both of these cohorts included H match
healthy control groups the wheezing
cohort was analyzed using 6 Pro quantum
asses while the asthmatic cohort was
analyzed for 3 targets with known
involvement in so-called type 2 asthma
so this is the basic workflow for the
quantum acids the ANSI format is based
on PCR amplification and use the
real-time PCR instrument which is why
the first thing one needs to do is a
program the cubies here cubies your
instrument we should say that any cube
user instrument should work for the LC
and the temperature profile is a
universal one so you can use the same
program for all houses the lab protocol
is prepared using the quantum app that I
mentioned and if there is available at
your official website so using it you
print the lab protocol and then you
follow the steps of the protocol either
as a digital copy or as a paper printout
here I would recommend when preparing
and setting up your asset that you do
use electronic micropipettes preferably
multi-channel ones so when the asset
plate has been set up you simply put it
into the cupids your instrument as you
would for any typical
qpcr on and you start the run you can
then conveniently progress for all of
the progress of the run from your cell
phone or your PC depending on what's
most convenient I think it's worth
briefly walking you through the program
the maps showing you how to design a
customized protocol from the thermo
Fisher web page one have access to
thermo Connect which is the portal for
all cloud-based apps including the
program to map you open the program to
map and start by clicking create
experiment next you enter the catalog
number for the kit you using and this
will autofill the entire page you can
then choose to also manually add the
lock number for the kit you're using and
after clicking next again you enter the
standard setup wizard that autofills
standards based on the number of
replicates and serial dilution interval
that you define
clicking next will take you to the plate
play out with you further define the
player tight layout by entering the
number of samples and fold dilution and
the plate setup wizard will complete
your acid lake next you will then save
the plate set up to the thermo Fisher
cloud and as a result in the last
picture number six you will have the
entire instructions for carrying out the
assets summarized in a one a two page
document and you will have the option to
print the lab instructions to bring to
your lab bench
you
you
it is most convenient to simply replace
the lab protocol printed on the lab
bench and just follow the steps of the
protocol when setting up the program LC
so briefly here here's how the acid work
for works what you do is to thaw and
prepare the other agents by nuclear
samples you prepare a serial dilution of
the standard this is done on a working
or setup plate which is simply an extra
plate you use to organize reagents
preparation of as the reagents and
pollution standard is straightforward
and simple process and as for the
preparation samples it's oftentimes
equally simple but maybe a little more
complex if you do a spike a recovery
experiment
so from this setup plate you then
transfer us reagent standards or samples
to the assay plate and the final step is
to start your run in a qPCR instrument
following the tempered temperature
profile mentioned at the end of the
protocol
you
program de masas utilize a proximity
ligation technology where the asset
combines the specificity of high
affinity antibodies with the signal
detection and amplification capabilities
for real-time PCR the LC is carried out
in two steps first as you can see on
your upper left-hand side you perform an
analyte binding step you combine sample
and detection antibodies and incubate
for one hour at room temperature on your
lab edge during this time the analytes
specific antibody pair will bind to your
molecule of interest
you then add qpcr reagents and place the
assay plate in your qPCR instrument
where you perform the second step on
your upper right this step comprises a
ligation event and it gives your readout
a few words about sample consumption
typically you dilute serum or plasma ten
times out of this you use either two or
five magnetic per well assuming you use
2 microliters sample one kit allows for
analysis of 48 samples if you run your
samples in triplicate and this means
that you would only use 0.6 microliters
of your original sample in total and
this is what attracted us the most if
you would compare it to analyzer you
typically use 25 to 50 micrometer rather
than those 0.6 mark ladies and from a
personal perspective I think once I get
used it this protocol is very simple and
quick and I have had the colleague run
it and she agrees as well and we in our
experience we run typically using one
instrument up to 3/4 plates per person a
day
another experience that we have is the
importance of using multi-channel
micropipettes preferably with the
stepper function and reason for using
multi-channel pipettes is obviously
because you handle many more samples in
parallel the stepper function makes
setup faster and more accurate in our
experience so again this is our strong
recommendation so a few words what's
happening inside the keep is your
instrument following the initial analyte
binding step which is carry out on your
lavage the subsequent ligation
amplification step is done in such an
instrument and this picture shows the
typical temperature profile that you use
in the upper left upper left part of the
picture you see the two analyte specific
antibodies as shown before and those are
linked to two different DNA oligos and
what happens when these antibodies bind
to the same molecule is that the DNA all
egos will come into close proximity and
if you also have a splint illegal
complementary to both of these DNA all
egos the do play a duplex structure will
form and you have the option amplifying
is following allegations event by DNA
ligase and the resulting molecule will
be amplified using those primers shown
on the right hand side including attack
map probe that will give the the present
readout so with the techni probes the
amplification is monitored real-time as
you can see this schematics example on
your right hand side and the PCR cycle
values when the signal rises above the
threshold will reflect and be used as a
determinant the protein concentration
similar to how you use cycle threshold
values for quantitation of DNA or RNA we
want a conventional qp0
some words
data analysis flow so once you run is
finished you have the option of choosing
at least the instrument we're using to
automatically upload your result to
connect on the cloud and once there you
open your program the map and using the
program to map you combine the plate
setup files that I described previously
with the result files generated now with
your cue piece your run and then you
have support for doing result analysis
within the app if you want to do a more
droughts analysis you have the option of
working more with your exported files
you can export PDF Excel and graphics
files to your local computer
so coming to our actual observations
this
slide shows the results from our program
tum' analysis of the we see children
cohort where we looked at seven
different human targets graphs your
group wise comparisons done it using
graphpad prism each graph shows wheezing
children compared to the healthy control
group and red lines indicate median
values gained on the y axis is
logarithmic prior to pro quantum
analysis we've assured the levels of a
protein called eosinophils dried
neurotoxin or edn using a research test
we have on our immunocal platform the
reason for doing is is the ideon is the
more careers in the fields and we have
previously observed an increase in this
protein in wheezing children as well as
aesthetics edn values are represented in
the graph in the upper left part of the
slide and we were curious to look at the
extent of correlation between edn and
the pro Crumpton cytokines so as a
result of our comparisons we observed an
increase in Aisle five and il-13
agreeing with edn levels and the role in
type two airway inflammation we did not
see an increase in your taxon became a
kind that attract significance moreover
we observed an increase in aisle six and
il-8 as mentioned previously those are
more markers of neutrophilic
inflammation and for interferon gamma
and marker buyer limitations the
difference between groups process there
with a greater spreading concentration
for the wheezing group
that is so therefore we looked at
correlation plots to see which of these
targets correlate on a group level
so what we can see is that while there's
no correlation at all between EDM and
cytokines in healthy children some of
the targets seem to show a correlation
and an increase correlating with adn in
for the wheezing children group and
trying to dissect this in the next slide
we
we look closely at the ones here here
looking more toast at the monster to
correlate we could see that il-6 and EDM
for the reason group seem to correlate
six is considered markers systemic
information and it's also known to be a
risk factor for development severus
there was also a seems to be there also
seems to be a correlation between
io8 and EDM and now it's also
interesting to note that both of these
satellites are produced in by air way
smooth muscle cells if we look at the
correlation between the different
programs of targets clogged against each
other we find some interesting
observations again scales on the axis or
in this slide logarithmic so while both
edn and il-5 showed an increase for the
wheezing group they did not clearly
correlate however both seem to correlate
12-6
as seen in the graph on the left hand
side of this slide and combined with
il-6 edn graphed on the former slide
that I showed you and as for your taxon
if you remember the form is light there
was no clear increase in the attacks and
when compared we seem to help the
children however as you can see on the
right hand side for the wheezing group
that seemed to be a correlation between
ill hexen ii o taxon and aisle 5 and we
believe that in order to further further
investigate this we will need to use
some multivariate approaches to shed
more light on the complex interactions
and correlations between all these
molecules involved
you
salt from our program tum' an ALICE away
of the asthmatic children court this was
a slightly older group with children and
all had a doctor's diagnosis of asthma
similar to our comparison between
wheezing and help the children we did
group wise comparisons and again we use
DD and a research marker on our
immunocal platform as a reference and
this is represented in the leftmost
graph for the asthmatics we anticipated
an increase in so-called type 2
inflammation markers this is why we
focus this analysis on aisle five eight
thirteen and he attacks
the role of il5 is known to be an
internal field activation of
proliferation while you're texting is
akima tracked and recruiting neutrophils
to sites of inflammation and asthmatic
success these children typically have an
increase in eosinophils numbers both
locally in the airways
and in the press room so therefore we
were Lin surprised to see that the
levels of i-95 an island 13 on a group
level were actually lower compared to
the healthy controls however I should
say that the spread in Aisle 5 and I
thought in wireless were was great
they're prismatic compared to healthy
making conclusions a little more
difficult to draw and there were a few
individual cases with where the cases
were higher than the controls for your
taxon however there was no clear
difference between the groups
we speculate that the reason we did not
see a clear increase in for example io5
could be due to the fact that these
individuals are treated this asthmatics
are typically treated with inhaled
corticosteroids and this treatment is
known to reduce the number of years in
the fields and of course this could
affect the outcome of the experiment
looking at the correlation between edn
and programs and targets we find some
intriguing observations again the scales
on the axis a lot of ethnic there seem
to be a negative correlation between you
Texan and edy and as you can see on the
left while there is it seem to be a
positive correlation between attacks in
an aisle five
this result is perhaps not intuitive
from the previous group price comparison
and as mentioned previously we believe
we will have to use the multivariate
approach to further resolve the complex
interactions between molecules amore and
hopefully clarify the pathways involved
in airway inflammation
start by mentioning some results we
obtained trying to analyze two other
sample matrices under blood
this slide shows measurement of programs
and targets in nasal mucosa lining fluid
the nasal fluid fluid was collected
before and after a grass cell is in
challenge in which in which the allergen
a grass extract or sprayed into the nose
of one individual at time 0 native fluid
collected at the indicated time points
were then analyzed for these 5 analytes
interestingly we could see a dramatic
increase in il5 and i13 as you can see
the upper part of the picture
following the grass silage and challenge
this would indicate an activation of
type 2 of the type 2 information pathway
and there is why the results from the
other side the guns were perhaps less
clear at least aisle 6 also seemed to
respond in a dramatic way following this
allergen challenge
in my final data slide I just want to
mention that we also explored the
possibility to get an even more complex
sample matrix-matrix fecal samples so
that's why we analyze human fecal
samples for the presence of il-1 beta
and il-8
protein was measured or extracted before
measurement using a dedicated students
traction kit and using this extraction
procedure it seems that both our lights
were readily measurable what we find
interesting is that the results although
the number of individuals is perhaps low
as a results indicate that these assays
are potentially sensitive enough to
measure basal levels and therefore
potentially able to discriminate between
these two different cancer intestinal
conditions coming to my conclusions most
protein acids like license would require
typically 25 to 50 microliters set with
pro quantum acids we use less than 1
micro litre even if we do two replicates
so to answer our own question can we do
more measurements or more analysed using
these program devices the answer is yes
the way we did this was to try to lect
the targets onto cohorts representing
two airway diseases wheezing in asthma
we also applied quantum ASUS programmed
masses to allergy research which we
looked at nasal samples following an
allergen challenge finally we apply to
the assists on gastrointestinal diseases
and fecal samples
mentioned that we used the specific
dedicated students tracking kit for
sample preparation you can find more
details about this on a webpage
altogether these analysis of course need
to be repeated to verify these results
and preferably on independent cohorts
but so far we think the results are
promising more targets are being
launched an additional program two
masses may add to the ability to
discriminate
for example as most asthmatics from
healthy
with this I want to thank you for your
attention and leave room for questions
Thank You dr. Mullen for urine
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. Mullen will answer as many questions
as time permits ok the first question is
did you need to handle your sample in
any specific manner for pro quantum
okay so in terms of this
the answer is that no there is no real
difference between simply handing for
this program the masses compared to for
example Eliza at one recommendation
though is that if you see any
particulates or any aggregates you
should give the your samples as a
centrifugation we you could so we
actually try this but we the way we
handle our samples was just use them as
is we did not have any Klaus problems
with particulars but a recommendation if
you want to be precautious is to do
centrifugation step prior to analysis
and are you able to detect other
cytokines than the ones in the example
here in particular I responded and want
sorry can't can you repeat the question
are you able to detect other cytokines
than the ones in the example here in
particular are spawned in and want WMT
okay so basically the ones we work with
so far are the ones presented here so we
didn't look at our responding or WMT
all right and what's the dynamic range
of the assay
the dynamic range is is if you can
remember for some asses the measure I
think they I gave one example for il-6
right the the measuring range falls from
0.06 per gram per milliliter up to I
think was thousand so that would be like
I don't know five or five a log
and can this essay be multiplexed
multiple analytes detected in each well
or is it single plugs only based on the
antibodies they're per analyte per well
I think the answer is that it is a
single place I see but I mean
technically you can ambition of course
in the future a multiplex version but I
don't know if this is on the table for
those developing for future analysis but
as a user I would say it's a single Plex
se
okay and what is the typical analytical
CV for these assays
so we in our experience you get
excellent
see these four standard curves typically
below 5% I would say sometimes you see a
little higher variation with the
biological samples but I think that that
is true for any essay and it could be
due to what we did talked about before
particulates aggregates will help
occurring in your samples so I would
suggest that you work with using a
repeated sorry and to make sure I mean
the way we work with with our samples
was to make sure that pipetting was
really accurate that we have those
samples the same way at all times and
also that you are try to avoid free soil
I mean if you do free soil some of the
analytes will with affected by the
cytokines are typically according to
literature they insensitive to resort
cycles so my also would be to to keep
those to those recommendations and we'll
have nice comparable series to other
else it's like license
and our custom antibody pairs conjugated
with the illegals available for analytes
not listed on your website and can such
antibody conjugates be created on
request
so while I'm not part of the program
term asset development team I know that
they there is a plan or they it's in the
process of being available service
activity so I think you can you at least
in the future you will be able to work a
custom message
and are there any washed steps before
PCR setup
no so the advantage with the program de
meses is that the different to realize
that you don't you don't have any wash
tips so there's this first analyze by
any step but then you have this combined
ligation amplification step within your
cue piece or instrument
and can the platform be used also for
gastro intentional inflammatory
yeah so what what I saw the day to the
preliminary data that they showed in my
final slide and suggest yes to that yes
the answer is yes to that question
that's what that's specifically what we
looked at two different gastrointestinal
inflammatory conditions
and do you need special qpcr instrument
or is rosh light-cycle 996 will be
suitable
and try any rush instruments or and I
never worked with the light cycler so I
can't tell but we used the quad Studio 5
as mentioned so but my according to
native mention I have is the app and the
platform should be open to any standard
cubed is your instrument
and is there a concern of antibodies or
protein analytes being denatured in the
denaturing and annealing steps of PCR
cycles or is the contribution of
antibodies only in the initial ligation
step and does it not interfere
afterwards so while I didn't do the
development work my guess is that
antibodies we locked into whereas after
a DNA only goes in like that and the
duplex formation occurs so the answer is
the antibodies only I have play role in
the first step
it will looks like that all the time we
have for questions or now I would like
to once again thank dr. Mullen for his
presentation we would also like to thank
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through August 2019 elaborate will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share the
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event till next time
goodbye